okay four people joining the livestream
we are in the late stages of reviewing
image and audio functionality for
version 12 after last week having a
technology conference previewing a lot
of stuff which seemed to work fairly
well and I got a cold which I'm at the
end of and so I'm in poor condition here
all right where we starting
we'll do next earth okay imager just do
I need to update documentation for this
yes
um
you can assume that documentation
changes all the time right this should
have been done okay all right so let's
just talk about um okay did we resolve
the design of a mesh pyramid in the end
because we were looking at that before
and we were there was some confusion in
the design is that thought now to be
done I think we're happy with this we
just wanted to run the whole oh all the
three functions by you one last time in
case you want to see it nothing really
has changed much okay uh okay
I was asking and the previous meeting
whether the facial features um stuff had
been whether the smaller neuron that
works for that we're in now
no but that's under in process yes okay
all right so we'll start with image
adjust here okay what am I looking at
the updated stuff are there named
correction schemes the ones they are
brightness channel wise and all note I
note that um I heard us work No
okay so hold on a second so where
is that oh I see okay let's make sense
these are a little bit obscure if I
might say so symmetric ones are very
useful when you get negative values as
well but but just let me understand the
naming scheme altogether here I mean one
thing says symmetric one thing says
brightness but they're both wait a
minute so some of these affect some of
the parameters and some affect others of
the parameters is that correct right
okay so the first question about these
is what so channel wise no I don't
understand
channel wise is sort of a different part
beach from symmetric
since Roger can you comment on this
place yeah you're right
so okay so we've got channel wise
symmetric okay let's look through this
okay so glue itself but you know
alphabetic is usually not the best order
to grouping wise necessary scales flu
range 0 to 1 so is it the case that's
symmetric and global are the ones are
the sort of things in you know are those
related are those the things is 102.5
I don't understand what which shaadi do
you understand what these are all doing
I do global is as opposed to channel
wise so that's one dimension we're
looking at whether we are taking them in
Max values of all the channels and map
that to 0 1 or do we what is the thing
in neural networks that is the that's
element wise is what we call it in
neural nets right correct okay so what
we've got here is we've got channel wise
ok so I'm trying to understand
brightness and lightness those are -
those are two things yes yes and those
are just adjusting for one channel
whether the B and HSB or L in LA B
so okay
so but these here this case is adjusting
by a particular number right correct and
what you're not doing here is to break
these into an association where you say
you know gamma correction error whatever
brightness error or whatever and okay so
what your suggestions should suggesting
is that maybe we should actually say
contrast for this channel or all
channels I'm think I'm saying that I'm
suggesting that what happens here is
that this breaks into some kind of
Association and that I mean I think it's
nice to have these short things but I'm
not quite sure that they're the right
short I mean global just seems obscure
believably obscure I agree channel wise
is very clear global I agree if you have
a better name for that you see how the
math works there right so we get min max
of all channels as if you flatten all
the data values yeah and then scale it
to zero and one which you typically end
up with a better scaling than if you do
channel wise which introduces new colors
yeah I get it
okay but global I can't tell that's the
whole picture or the whole you know all
channels correct I mean the word
combined it seems better than I mean I
don't know what we have for other and I
don't understand the word symmetric
either here so symmetric is when you
have numbers that range from say minus
0.1 to 0.5 and then you want the zero to
be the absolute gray point five which is
a very common scaling yeah I understand
I understand I understand so then I
don't know why that's called symmetric
though I mean it's zero I mean what that
really is is centered around zero
correct I mean it's it's more like zero
centered but
want is not 0 centered right you're
taking it from the zero centered case to
thee I mean this is super confusing
because some of these are destinations
some of them are sources right symmetric
is a source designation here right
that's correct yes
whereas channel wise is not a source
designation it's something completely
different okay
is it the case that there are just a set
of parameters here so what one says is
um you know that it's essentially
destination range and then it's interval
0 1 or something source range bla bla
bla
that's the 3rd 4th argument that you're
talking about right we already have
those oh I see I see okay
okay well it's more about which channels
to adjust you know okay but so so that's
a substitute that's a replacement for I
mean maybe you should have a string name
for the instead of the ins and the outs
here right
instead of um you could do that third
argument could you could say zero
centered or you could say um automatic
or something there or something and that
would be that would be zero one right
for the in out and similarly in the
output you could do the same thing um
but then here somewhere you're saying
whether to treat the channel separately
or not right that's correct so that's
that's at which a different issue I mean
that's that's a completely new feature
of amateur just if I'm not mistaken
that's correct it actually started as a
separate function and then it became
this we tried to merge it into him image
adjust mean it's an option to image
adjust whether to adjust all channels at
the same time well no I see this is
really that is kind of yeah I mean this
contrast brightness gamma correction
those are really so I don't understand
where it says rescales the brightness
but here it's giving the amount of
rescaling right yeah when we say rescale
the brightness it means rescale to zero
one which is the one arc form of image
adjust okay um how do you reproduce that
by giving the two argh form rescale
brightness to zero one how do you what
is the two our version of that there is
no two art form you will have to color
separate color combined okay listen I
think this is a mess okay ah let's try
to
back to this I mean this is not this is
not right and you know my best
compromise would be if we were
absolutely running out of time let's
simply not document these things this
version okay but but um I mean I'll be
nice to solve it but you I think this is
not properly orthogonalize I agree with
you okay well see if you can see it why
don't you do an iteration on it then
sure okay all right let's look at image
pyramid okay so last time it's been a
few months here so I'm forgetting a
little bit what the deal is with this so
how can you say create something formed
from well okay so let's take an image
here oops let's take that guy um why is
that a single image it was large we
rasterize the whole thing okay okay so
now you say image pyramid here and you
get is somewhat incomprehensible
creature excuse me
okay so I don't really understand what
that is so how am I going to use this
how do i how do I go from the image
pyramid is that laceless
me okay so if I were to say for example
for these if I were to say blur / out
each of those and then I would say
inverse image pyramid that wouldn't work
right like that you would you would have
to say pyramid all levels equals Blair
or you can use image pyramid apply blur
and then do inverse image pyramid on
that but missus so here if I say I see
image pyramid apply of let's say
binarize just for fun onto the image
pyramid and then I say inverse image
pyramid as opposed to from image pyramid
correct why is it inverse rather than
from and inverse transform is it really
I mean is it nice mathematical
properties of inversing think so I mean
it's expected ly a junior wavelet hmm
and wavelet has an inverse wavelet I
mean it's some yes okay huh I don't
really know what I'm doing here so how
does it oops what's that what is that to
have a brush
can you screencap that and figure out
what's going on thank you okay and you
got what what I did to get that yes yes
okay
so what happens if I'm I mean I don't
quite understand what when when I'm
doing image pyramid apply is that
applying the same function to every no I
see I see I see I see I see I see you
can do both you can apply the same
function to all levels or you can apply
a function on a list of images from
corresponding levels but how if I don't
but what about if I don't know how many
levels there are is there a default
number of levels and why don't I why
can't have a function whose like a map
indexed well the second argument is the
level number we thought about having
that as well we trusted then well we
have it in the image context if you want
us to by the way by the way it's small
smallest to here for my know this this
doesn't have its thumbnail here okay you
see that right do you understand what
I'm talking about yeah okay all right it
seems unproblematic to apply f with two
arguments here but maybe that's maybe
that's wrong no that's wrong because you
couldn't then just say blur right mm-hmm
what is the typical case that you want
to do one of the womb' category of
functions is multi scale feature
extraction like you want to do saliency
detection edge detection and so forth on
all that on all resolutions or scales
and then you aggregate all the results
okay but it's not what this is doing for
example here and
that doing I mean so Wow I mean how do I
know all of these things like gaussians
and I mean what would happen if I just
said it's okay so that's giving me the
four level image pyramid is that correct
correct so and I should use zebras
because otherwise they don't have enough
stripes correct okay okay so now if I
simply say inverse I mean I don't really
understand what this is doing so that
that's that's b laplacian so i don't
understand what those okay I didn't
understand that I'm suggesting we have
some other names for inverse image
pyramid type or goal there there are two
type two very typical ways we would like
to access data in a permit either just
sample a level that has the right
resolution or aggregate or combine all
the results when we say na plazi and now
it means aggregate everything so it up
samples add to the previous level N and
goes all the way up but so I don't quite
understand I mean in the inverse case
what what you were doing here if I just
take percent nine and I look at the sub
value all I'm getting something which is
kind of at some level like the inverse
image pyramid correct yes that's kind of
screwy
so on the
and sub valuing into the image pyramid
itself gives images and on the other
hand inverse image pyramiding I mean
soap so if I were to do but not if your
initial pyramid is in La Crosse hamper
on me what do you mean you can you can
say what kind of pyramid you want to
construct take that zebra and say image
pyramid come up and a plush you
okay so now this the zebra will be more
black-and-white even a zebra no oh okay
so um did you see this output in this
output right that's what Manu that's
what generated this self-test error okay
did you get that right so so let me send
you you you're gonna need to pick up in
this let's see if I can just send this
to you mm-hmm
right because otherwise we won't be able
to reproduce this and that won't be any
good
you
you
oh my gosh this thing is barely oh my
gosh it's freezes my mail application
trying to copy/paste this that's not a
good sign
okay but then you have to go you have to
know where this comes from in the
Superman apply etcetera etcetera well it
just crashed my my mail app that's
exciting okay but so what are these
black things here these are the
differences between levels of the
downsampled image if you open image
pyramid it's actually I can see there's
a there's a very ghostly zebra here yep
so if I say image adjust for example on
that Ghost zebra
I see sorry what are you saying if I
open image which one image chairman on
there details there is an illustration
that shows the two main types okay right
that's blurring that's differencing
right correct what does that mean
low-pass comma Gaussian that's not two
arguments is it wasn't there they're
synonyms and the reason why we added
both is that Gaussian and laplacian are
very well known in the literature but
then you may want to define other
kernels like what you can do in the
third fourth cause of that table so in
those cases they are technically not
yeah I would recommend for this
documentation comment or would be better
than comma here because it's a bit
confusing oh okay
okay so let's see so where were we here
so we were at the question of whether
inverse image pyramid so you claim that
that's like inverse wavelet transform
yeah yes but it goes back from an image
pyramid to an image which sounds
reasonable to me
but it's very weird that we're going
down as Gaussian and back up as
laplacian that's really weird well it's
a hack see I'm saying it's it's it was
for that application and I don't think
it's super appropriate as a basic
example because I think that needs to be
comment that explains you know how you
define fine because otherwise I would
imagine that the default inverse image
pyramid would be to recover the image
using the same assuming the same pyramid
type yeah exactly so an often the thing
that you want to do some operation at
different scales you know like a blend
there's a typical classical example is
blending at different scales yes or you
might do some filtering at some very
well so if you want to do it at
different scales is it the case that you
can just do that at a particular scale
yeah Nermin apply how do you do that
because you'd have to say identity
identity identity blah blah blah doesn't
seem right to me that's where something
like image pyramid apply index would be
useful or map index well I know I'm sure
that's the right way to do it I mean why
not have some kind of sparse
specification here where you just say 3
arrow and then the function to say do it
at level 3 yeah if it's just a one level
setting we also can do there now Lanyu
setting you can say pure 3 equals there
what were you saying about 3 I've got
some L value insanity I thought we
agreed on the fact that they're not in C
okay I don't like it but any case
I mean look I don't think
is the fantastic design I mean I know we
went through this in some detail but but
I think you know I don't really
understand what would cause one to do a
blur at level three for example or a
blend at level three what would that
then look like if I just adjust what
happens I mean again it's very very
inconvenient what I'm being asked to do
here right because in this case if I go
let's say Gaussian here and do I need to
say the word Gaussian before I say four
or can I just say four no is that really
right seems like okay so okay so I've
got the Gaussian thing now what I do
keeps on generating those self-test
errors so if I say image pyramid apply
and then what I'm gonna have to do wait
a minute can I give a list of functions
there no how do i how do I change what
happens at different levels or is it
always the same function being given to
every level very typically it's the same
function that you want to apply to
different scales but again something
like image pyramid mapping mixer apply
index would be the way to specify yeah
but that seems really grotesque to have
to do that I mean you know one
possibility that you may want to change
when you go from a level to another
level is to change say say there's scale
or range specification which then make
very a lot of sense to actually be able
to do it with image from a defined X
sorry the range specification of what
kind say the radius for Blair yes it
makes a lot of sense to want to do that
right depending on the size of the image
for example I mean I could do that by
just looking at
dimensions right when I the F function
could look at image dimensions right and
maybe you should document that that's
possible okay I mean that seems like
it's the I don't even know I mean when
you make an image pyramid this is always
a factor of two we have a scaling factor
after the end levels after that's four
you can say what other factor you want
to use okay I this these functions seem
a little raw to me I would recommend
that we make them experimental I agree
okay let's not obsess about them right
now I think they I think we should pick
them up again later um they're probably
okay for right now we have a question on
the live stream that does it support
pyramid blending I think the answer was
yes right that's that's the multi
pyramid case correct we have an example
on their image pyramid I think instance
I'm a suggestion here the classic orange
to Apple blend would be a nice example
it's the one that's the one under what
image pyramid go to application
effects Mirage that
all scales I see that's an app orange or
something so okay so this is so why why
are you even showing this I mean this is
just that has nothing to do with image
pyramid this thing up here right no this
is just taking the first the left half
from image one okay okay function in the
repository okay so what is this doing
this is an image pyramid I don't
understand this here map but it's the -
- now we're getting that we are getting
two pyramids from Apple and orange I
agree we should probably just flip this
into orange pyramid Apple from it just
make it easier yeah and I don't know
what split merge is doing here this is
just super confusing to me that's just
super confusing I mean this is just do
it using the same function which
arguably is a function that will be
useful to have I don't know what I mean
I I'm amazed that it's so complicated to
do that why is it so complicated to do
that why isn't that just some image take
of scaled of a halt for something right
maybe we have scale either I'll look
into it good and if not it makes sense
to add image takes guilt yes I would
think so um okay so anyway pyramid stuff
will be experimental for now do we want
at least quickly talk about the name
image parameter ploy
should it be image pyramid apply which
comes from image apply function that we
have or image pyramid map and then
eventually maybe image pyramid map
indexed
you know the image apply is a
element-wise of application right quick
pixel wise application yeah I do think
image brilliant map would be better um
question our live stream any chances for
virtual image stack for handling
displaying processing big images um I
think we have a bunch of things but
that's not related to image pyramid is
it we are gonna have a back-end of image
pyramids possibly as a new modality or
internal representation of images which
is gonna help display and processing of
large images but that's not true of
having sort of the low res version come
in earlier the low res version is easier
to handle in core so to speak with the
high res version deeper in the pyramid
being on a file is that the idea or what
yes or everything being on file but then
accessing than the res is gonna be much
faster okay um yeah point being made
here another used to varnish permits is
creating a high fidelity image from said
images taken with different focal
lengths shutter speeds etc I'm not
specifically aware of that I don't quite
understand that um maybe maybe I mean
that that requires that you take a bunch
images and essentially reweighed s--
them into an image pyramid if I'm not
mistaken by saying this image is higher
resolution and more important these
other images are going to be washed out
by being at different levels in the
pyramid or maybe I'm confused can you
comment on that No
although yeah right okay no but okay
well okay so these are gonna become
experimental I Roger what do you think
about changing it to image permanent map
well I think if MIT's fits better with
the rest of the language and we wavelet
can happen and so on and is there a
wavelet map I think so to go what called
I thought it was wavelet apply actually
but well well let's look that up indexed
hmm
okay but is there also wavelet that's
interesting there isn't a wavelet so
maybe there should be an image image
pyramid map indexed it's kind of its
kind of more important for wavelets
because and they're bigger
you know you get get sort of four images
every level down so no I mean we decide
it that way because you exactly for the
discussion we had there here which was
to be able to focus in on certain areas
and right so I mean I guess my question
would be in the image pyramid case is it
ever useful other than for demos to
apply the same function to every level
yeah one of the very typical examples is
computing some features at different
scales
yeah but how do you recombine those you
mean features as in like that edge
detection thing for the zebra right
right for instance salient regions right
and then you really want to blow up the
significance of a small region at a
small scale if it's a but what this
suggests to me is that one could imagine
something like edge detect right like a
scale invariant version of edge detect
saying yes but then maybe we need a an
image you know just forget pyramids and
unpair Ahmed's
you know package that up and basically
say you know scale invariant image apply
or image map of edge detects
and have something else to take you know
have something else deal with that so
I'm saying so it automatically creates
the pyramid does the application
reassembles it
that's the operation ones really talking
about that's a good idea do we then want
to have rotation invariant functions as
well
yeah I think well so ok so what those
would be
is what you're saying is if there is a
like say a corner detector right now you
want what's that
yes then then you could imagine just
having a mechanism that just says apply
this corner detector detector with
translation rotation and scaling you
know accounted for so to speak crap that
seems useful to me agree I mean honestly
seems more useful I don't know you know
the right okay let's make image pyramid
experimental so the only question is
whether it's image pyramid map or image
pyramid apply Roger what do you think or
map indexed well I've always been
slightly confused with image apply
however we arrived at at at the time it
was because image map kind of feels like
geographic maps that was the argument
behind not calling it image map okay hey
Roger I
no question about the polyhedra meeting
that's on the agenda for later today
I think maybe you should cancel that
because I I can't guarantee that things
are gonna look well the so then in that
case what we should probably do is move
the LCC meeting into that slot if that's
possible and then we can continue with
this because we've clearly got more to
do here can um can someone figure that
out please can we do that okay all right
so learn then we're gonna keep going
here um and we'll hope for polyhedra
like tomorrow ish that's okay if that's
okay
all right um so okay well do okay so in
a whisper map or map indexed I would be
comfortable with both we don't want to
have both its de más I mean we don't
have both for wavelets so one thing that
I was worried about this that this
pyramid would introduce a whole stack of
functions around it there's like a whole
basic derivative functions ya know go
right just bunch of code administration
functions you know map dis at that do
this and that you know Vietnam which is
you know not so good no it's not I mean
I
you think it's a little bit raw
functionality but it's also very
promising functionality it's some of the
people on the stream
I'm sure knows great applications you
know - we just don't I don't feel it's
all right let's leave it as image
pyramid apply for now it's an
experimental function it may get you
know revised into something else I don't
think we're ready to figure out map map
indexed etc and then in fact my guess
would be yeah I mean I don't even know
how successful the design of the wavelet
stuff is do you have a sense of that
Roger well the big downside was that our
timing wasn't great for wavelets and the
the app the key applications I mean it's
actually very powerful but they require
some learning on the part of people so
some key applications we don't really
care about like compression the
compression has been sort of a key
driver for wavelets but you know who'd
have writes their own compression
algorithm I mean you cannot use you know
and and and then their sort of feature
detection at though levels like you can
actually find discontinuities very
reliably with wavelets or French
differentiate very reliably it's
powerful but are we using wavelets and
our other functionality we're not maybe
we should but we I mean like like our I
mean in in some of our feature detectors
we should yeah we should and it's it's
you know so image processing team has
taken over wavelets so we cannot sort of
gradually start to absorb and and
integrate what about on the audio side
same thing
okay and we've updated them so they
actually support a new audio object
because we built them
support sampled sound back then and then
added audio and then we added audio now
that we have audio okay so we did them
for both audio and image at the time but
it was just it needed to be updated okay
all right let's keep going so the
conclusion is it's gonna be in there
experimental with image pyramid apply
sounds good as designed here okay need
an option to specify maximum allowed
overlap
Mattox overlap fraction um this is what
you suggested in there
machine learning meeting fine what does
this mean this is whether we want so
four fine faces it doesn't make sense
because all the only object we are
detecting is faces but in image contents
the question is do you want to get
overlapping cats and dogs but don't want
to have overlapping cats so we haven't
really designed or implemented this but
it would be nice to have a setting for
max overlap fraction that says do we
want the overlap to be computed globally
across all classes or all right but I
mean this is this seems like okay so
look for each class right you could
imagine an association here that says
cat arrow whatever right you can allow
jellyfish to overlap because they might
do but you can because they're
translucent but you can't allow cats to
overlap because they're not translucent
somehow well that's not really right
anyway there could be a cat partial it's
going another cat bad example but but um
but I mean I would I would say you it
will be either the max overlap fraction
or an association for the different
types or well I don't understand what
the single global thing is what does
that mean hey
global across all classes with the
default threshold T which is typically a
50% overlap okay I this is
incomprehensible to me I mean in other
words this that to me it seems like what
you should be doing is saying either
right so it's either okay so max overlap
fraction okay point three so I'll point
whatever it is you know okay point five
fine whatever so that's the traction of
the bounding box or the faction of the
mask bounding box if we have bounding
box eventually we could have apparently
all we have for image contents and find
faces is the bounding box eventually it
could be very fine shape that's gonna
cause an incompatibility isn't it I mean
in other words we have to decide whether
the overlap fraction what determines
whether the overlap fraction is measured
with respect to the bounding box or with
respect to the shape
do a little nicely yeah yeah okay but
but separately to me it seems like the
right thing here is we're saying things
like you know dog arrow whatever it is
dog arrow point seven whatever right and
we're the default would be essentially
well either blank arrow whatever
anything is point seven but now I don't
understand what you mean by now by this
global which probably should be all I
think this in that the more specific
syntax is gonna be dog can overlap with
cats but not with snakes or something
like that how do we specify that if you
want to be specific if you don't I guess
the two settings we had in mind was
either really check for overlap across
all classes or only within the class the
detected class it's the same it's okay
within a given class so that's cats with
cats okay that's globally across classes
cats with anything well anything with
anything
and finally specifically between classes
right well I mean seems to me that
you've answered your own question here
because because basically what what's
gonna end up being would be something I
mean it's kind of complicated but but
you know if you need it and we can give
it you might as well give it I mean
something like this cat dog arrow
whatever it is mm-hmm
and then one could imagine things like
cat all that yeah that's doable but what
is the difference between cat comma all
and just cat on its own so cat on its
own is cat with cat that's that correct
the default in other words dog arrow
point seven is equivalent to dog dog dog
eats dog so to speak
okay now we're fine okay
well I mean is this implementable I
think so yes
okay but then those categories might be
at different levels as well so I was
thinking about that that's okay that's
fine I mean you know animals can overlap
animals but they can't overlap trees all
right fine I mean what we get for this
version might be so hold on what does
that what is the meaning of all here
which is what I think global should be
if it isn't I think the default tea
should just be an overlap between all
classes yes I agree anything with
anything basically yes um but I mean
there'll be a
pert argument that determines what
you're looking for you're looking for
animals or plants or whatever there is a
category yes right so that's what you
consider then okay so question if there
is a category not being searched for but
which an overlap is detected with what
happens let's say I only wanted to look
at animals I'm using image contents just
with animals but there's an animal
overlapping a tree what happens or a
tree overlapping an animal what happens
I guess I guess we don't eliminate it
because we don't look for as we much
aligned to the tree basically think so I
think that makes more sense okay fine
then what is the meaning of this global
thing here I don't see what it means I
mean in other words it's saying because
that seems like that's what this is
doing that's exactly set global
equivalent to zero no overlap no I don't
think so surely said it was a default
overlap right so I don't know what the
Cobell means I think we should not do it
I think for this version we should just
have a single number and for in the
future we should have this binary thing
like this makes sense
yep so in fact the default okay so
there's a little tricky because what
you're telling me is the default default
the the T thing is this but what does
all mean does all mean all orders in
other words is all equivalent to
essentially X blank x blank or is it
equivalent to blank blank get what I'm
asking other words like black black okay
so there are no no to detections that
have more than T overlap right right so
that's
for any so then the only question would
be if you would care about self overlaps
but not in other words about the case X
Blanc X Blanc as distinct from the Blanc
Blanc case right which your first syntax
up there dog goes to a single our dog
goes to point seven is convenient to
specify that and then I I think it would
be useful to give that a name so that or
maybe we just say on their score goes to
point 7 for which for the case that we
want to say within a single class we
don't want overlaps well I mean there is
another name we could use such as in any
I I don't know I mean we can also use
the the pattern variable pattern case I
think this is immature I think we need
to work this out later okay um did you
capture this this notebook or should I
be storing it somewhere I did okay okay
chromaticity plot 3d if you open color
sneer there is a there is a if I
evaluated version I don't think I've
boarded it here
that's pretty cool actually that's
colorspace okay well where's it
spherical if you would have to specify
the distance function that third
argument of color is near so that it is
the Euclidean in la be but women when
you say colors near here isn't there a
more minimal example than this I mean
can't you just say I mean shouldn't you
show an example in basic examples that
says you know that does a green screen
or something that's right I put that on
their applications you're right I'll
bring one up to their main examples okay
but but are you saying here
so if I say chromaticity plot 3d well
actually let me just do chromaticity
plot to start with and then I'm saying
um oops colors near red so let's do this
is the most basic thing okay I don't
understand what happened here why don't
I see some some if you do cloak
chromaticity plot 3d you're gonna start
what why does Julie and I have talked
about this a lot
the default is well maybe we should
project already as well
the the question is that do we want and
a cross-section of the 3d plot or do we
want a projection of the 3d plot oh yeah
colors near represents a family of
colors near red correct correct okay
in the 2d whatever those colors are put
them on the 2d chromaticity plot I
understand I don't know what shape
they're gonna be you have to tell me
that I don't know how it projects but
but there should be a shape in the 2d
chromaticity plot that represents colors
near red if you add a point 3 comma
point 3 to your chromaticity plot you're
gonna start seeing cross-sections of the
3d shape repeat what you're seeing is at
luminosity level 0 so the bottom of the
shape so this
is currently a crime totally confused
luminosity what I mean this it looks
like a bunch of colors why am i why is
it luminosity zero open the page you
might hisses applause you missing a
dimension Steven so yeah yes I
understand that but but so what so
you're looking at a different slice now
if I might say so this would should
surely did a minimal example something
like this should surely be a minimum
example vote for colors near rather than
that much more complicated thing and if
I might say so these seem like crummy
examples for chromaticity right you
should just give something where you've
got a list of colors right I mean
chromaticity product you should be able
to unless I'm very confused here
chromaticity plot of something like or
an image actually you should show it
these are silly basic examples if I
might say so it should show an image
here the chromaticity plot for an image
because that's the number one use rather
than these very nerdy things about wide
gamut are jeebies right these are the
color scientists who care about these
things a lot but for us yeah we can we
can do that all changes okay well you
can include one of those as well but but
Tim okay so I can barely see those
points but they are there okay so
explain to me why colors near red okay
so I am totally confused now because red
is showing up in this picture so why
aren't colors near red also showing up
in this picture we're yeah if you have
the chromaticity plot 3d right or read
the read the text above the
illustrations in chromaticity plot it
says we are getting the inner section
and one intersection if you will the
details details sorry I was looking at
my own documentation displays a slice
by constantly winnin 0.01 I don't
understand that at all I mean if I take
a picture of a you know let's say I've
got look okay picture of an elephant
okay what I'm looking for here is that
elephant hopefully I'll get a picture of
the African bush elephant okay fine
you
okay so what I had understood was that
the cluster of pixels that I see here
correspond to I mean in this picture
there are pixels displayed of a certain
color correct what I had understood was
I'll see a dot for every pixel in this
image at the position in which it occurs
in that color image in that chromaticity
image is that right and this is
projected what is projected mean well
the colors are in the 3d space they they
don't all have i suture saying so in
other words these colors are flattened
onto this chromaticity block because
we're ignoring their luminance correct
right okay I get it
am I going crazy
font for this sum for the numbers here
different from the usual font has
something completely nuts yeah it's
different isn't it I don't have your
eyes for this I don't know
well it looks like looks a bit lighter I
agree I mean it might not be wrong to
make it lighter I suppose I would be
very surprised if you're changing it
yeah I I don't think it's obviously
wrong the way it looks I just doesn't
look the same way that it normally looks
um okay okay so I think I understand
what you're doing here so now explain to
me why the colors near red doesn't
similarly project itself onto luminance
sir effectively which means that colors
near red so I'm saying the colors near
red would be some ball of colors that
have certain luminance associated with
them but then you're going ignore the
luminance and just project them onto the
2d chromaticity plots we can't do that
Julie and I discussed this both ways we
couldn't really agree which cases a more
dominant wanted well it seems to me it's
utterly confusing to not have you know
to not have I mean if I say colors near
red it's like I could have a you know I
mean for example when I say colors near
red if I would have visualized that I
could have a is there had a way to do
that to make an image from colors near
red that is effectively a randomly
chosen okay so if I see a random image
we would like to have random random
sample random variate from the colors
near that would be very useful
okay so random image could have that as
a distribution there it's men who can
you report another thing that is driving
me crazy which is that when I am doing
this I'm not getting the cursor on the
raft is not changing okay okay so what
I'm sick
justing here and maybe you already have
that right now okay so you have a
distribution there and the question is
whether the distribution where is the
distribution specified it's just any any
random distribution any of our existing
I see I see I see
so min max could be colors near red
correct that first argument we should
accept colors near so but in particular
then for ordinary distributions if you
want something which says numbers around
point to numbers around point seven
etcetera I don't think we have an easy
way to do that to me Roger first
standard statistical distributions that
is essentially a bunch of step functions
around given or intervals around a given
value uniform no I understand but if you
want several uniform things right so
let's say I want something which is you
know a blob around red a blob around
green for example how do I do that with
with distributions how do I combine
those distributions okay so there are
many ways to combining I'm thinking of
sickle split okay well in any case
versus there is a common case like that
which is often used to sort of take a
distribution but have a different tail
for it so the body is one distribution
to tailors and other is a very common
where you have several and we built one
that does just that perfectly
okay by the way on a live stream a
question from Ali Hashmi says have a
user of image processing functionality
wants to ask where the image content can
be used for annotating objects in images
yes the answer is yes image contents if
you're asking does image contents have
convenient ways to to have ala - great
why isn't it in there in which contents
documentation doesn't seem to be there
yeah it hasn't we have as soon as it's
retrained to actually return a decent
number of classes we're gonna document
it it since Cronus um spliced
distribution is is the one that allows
you to splice different distributions
okay okay all right so several things
here so image contents first question is
can you take image contents and can you
annotate the image with an image
highlight type thing question yes yes if
you get the bounding boxes we can hide
well I think that I think that they
implicit in that users question is
something that's highly interesting
which is to speed up image annotations
correct
okay so build more stream up because
it's super slow to annotate images right
so to speed that up would be not too
hard I think there's a different
question which is can you take the
result the data set for image contents
and immediately fill it fill it feed it
to image highlight so that you can put
in highlights that say you know that
have a bounding box around the dog and
say dog for example yeah yeah we have a
prototype of that it's coming so that's
a yes but but also related to that is
like image tagging you know you're gonna
tag different parts you know I think
it's what we're talking about here if
I'm not mistaken yep okay but when an
earth is this message by the way okay
cat and dog here okay so then then the
workflow that we're expecting here is
something where you literally say image
highlight then what is it corn hi
image highlight image mmm highlight
image right where you say highlight
image and then you give the original
image yeah and then you give that
Association is that correct or what do
you give their event the function image
bounding boxes eventually which is an
association of dog goes to the rectangle
I see so that instead of image contents
if I'd said and there's something
horribly wrong with the selector image
bounding boxes of that image correct yes
oops what do I have to say here oh maybe
I out the category dog should default to
all I think so yeah I think so too
one argument form should exist then okay
so given that the question is does this
work now nod now okay but that will yes
okay I mean that seems nice to me and
then like many other demos we have seen
or shown from these guys all the cats
are going to be colored the same color
and so forth which is visually very so
so you you put bounding boxes around
cats as purple and all dogs yeah right I
didn't but the cat itself has not been
painted no the bounding box okay fine
all right this this we could call this
the self-driving car you know so to
speak
um I'm still trying to figure out what
what causes my car to think the thing in
front of it as a deer it has an icon for
that and I just want to know what the
what its catchment area is anyway never
mind that
okay all right what's that all to leave
build these image safety systems that
aren't broadly applied to vehicles okay
which we worked on from mathcore okay so
it may be our text that's actually
determining the deer um it's always it's
always amazing that a bit you know the
technology goes in at one level a minute
at some point one becomes a consumer of
it and one has no idea how how it
actually is applied anyway okay so
question from Sandra on the livestream
random color of colors near red that's a
reasonable idea yep yeah that seems like
a thing that should work correct
okay Roger do you have any objection to
this thing about crushing the about this
thing about projecting so what will this
look like if you if you project colors
near red I mean I don't know what's
gonna happen if I go what happens here
if I go 0.5 or something disappeared
again where did that disappear again you
just you're not at that level anymore
what at what level I don't understand
what level we're talking about here so I
mean if I say level um L or something
here and I say L from point from 0 to
0.5
in steps of 0.1 what am I gonna see here
I'm gonna see a bunch of errors but I
don't understand what this airfoil
looking creature is um this is really
the cross
the 3d block just look at their 3d
version of its assume we can see can
visually see where it is okay so then I
don't have to give so I just say
chromaticity plot 3d colors near red and
that's it yep so let's see where it's
nice but then you want their gamma - so
you probably want to add in there
nor GP what do you want to do in RGB
space yeah no no in the first argument
you can do that as well I'm now totally
confused okay so that's where that is an
RGB space correct but what Roger was
suggesting was putting them in a list in
their first argument listen I am firmly
confused here okay so the red point is
over here at at red value of y is this
what is this a solid filled in blah blah
well I don't understand I'm really
confused
what it it should be solid isn't
utilized a solid to turn thing but it's
does it lacking its its some its edges
here I mean is it lacking its places but
if they're at the bounding box I don't
know whether that's I think that it's is
visualizing there
three of it and okay weird hole where
what is this shape I would expect that
an RGB space this would be some fairly
uniform thing as no no no it's all in
perceptual space - yeah we're using the
CIE 2000 colors color this says there's
a weird
Oh okay all right fine okay so that
might whole you know that that might be
a bug from RN but the shape of the book
okay so this is colors perceptually neo
red like okay perceptually near pure red
basically you have to remember RGB is
physics has nothing to do with
perception no I realized that um
okay so let me just try to understand
again
so you're saying so this picture here is
a squashing down of the beacons you can
see it Stephen if you do the list string
RGB comma colors near in chromaticity
plot 3d
but let me just narrator bear well I
want to see this case there's gonna be
somewhat pathological isn't it hmm what
the heck is that
it's just this is just a default plot
range that is used notice notice the
axes takes be from minus 4 to minus 2
yeah
that's that's how that color is near red
is defined so colors near red has
support for negative values of RGB it
does it's just the transformation from
that CIE 2000 color space to RGB
we don't clip we avoided clipping in
many places in the system it just helps
us preserve the values when we're round
tripping between color spaces okay fine
all right so how do I show so can I say
plot range arrow RGB or something here
that's not supported but you can't say
plot range 0 1 okay
shouldn't we have to arrange our RGB but
then plot range arrow la B is not really
well-defined because it's not bound that
space anymore okay so what do i do just
this okay what
for my seeing here okay so RGB now
probably we have we need to have three
of those if you wanna write so what's
happening here is that in in so that's
in our space so that that cuboid thing
is the arch at the boundary of RGB space
that's the zero one RGB space yeah it
makes sense
RGB yes exactly that's zero one RGB
space okay that intersects the near red
which is this weird airfoil shape with a
slightly serrated pieces it looks very I
mean what is it is an interpolation
function what is that thing
for LA B we are representing this as a
parametric plot so it's it's
nice-looking and all of that in all
other spaces this is a region plot
wasn't it an interpolating function we
don't have where why would you have an
interpolating function in in graphics
fair enough okay so it's a pleasantly
defined region of some kind right but I
really shouldn't use region plot I mean
I've told you that many times yeah but
we couldn't yeah it's it's we you should
use parametric plot of some kind yeah or
contour plot but you're basically saying
resolve it so it's not a set of
inequalities yeah the region plot solves
a much more general problem so the
question here is if you were to project
this if you were to show this in the in
the 2d case should you project all I
mean to me it seems like it makes sense
to do that to project all the things you
know but can get get rid of the the lost
RGB argument to RGB plot 3d so we can
see how it relates today gamma 2 to D
gamma that's shown because that's so
confusing otherwise okay
okay now from livestream someone is
suggesting by the way color project as
it as an option true/false yeah yeah I
guess that would resolve it the other
thing is that for the illuminance level
that we picked 0.3 earlier we can use
that slot and say all or some string
like project if you want to project and
that could be the default if you want
sorry I'm sorry I what what chromaticity
plot the 2d plot has this luminance
level that is that if that defaults to
0.01 that was the one that Steven you
were putting in your table you see all
the levels that argument we can accept
things you know a predefined setting
like all or project as string project or
something like that as well so that we
explicitly project and that projector
than all I I guess we can use them as
synonyms for this case okay so women
this is an XYZ chromaticity space is
that right yes XY Y okay and that's the
boundary of RGB in that space showing
also the the lump of perceptual colors
near red yes
okay so now to get the the 2d version
what is the projection that's done and
look at it from the top
projecting on little X little Y like
that okay but no they said we don't put
we actually get a cross-section so if
you ask for arch chromaticity plot of
RGB you get it wrong I mean in other
words for the elephant that you put in
that particular room right some you know
we're taking all the pixels of the
elephant and we're projecting them onto
that XY plane yes yes okay so I don't
understand if we're doing that if we're
projecting the elephant why aren't we
projecting colors near as well we can't
if you think okay well I mean if we're
project we can't be got to be consistent
either that or you could say of the
elephant show me only um
pixels that are between Capital y value
of 0.3 and point 6 or something which we
don't currently support what do we want
to do then for color spaces like RGB
like exactly that gamut that you're
showing now should that as well be
projected by default and then if you
explicitly ask for a luminance level we
slice um that's a question of
expectation there because the one we
show now right for the gamut is that
it's sliced right that sliced yes what
everybody expects that's what everybody
expects but arguably the gamut could be
different you know gamut is like a base
and then these things above it like you
know the elephants pixels and things are
you know those are being projected I
mean look we already crossed the bridge
of projection things by projecting from
so I think any of the content should be
projected okay but the gamut should not
okay okay so um okay let's zoom out here
so the projection question is that
second argument to chromaticity plot all
would mean project everything I would
assume now I don't know about to cut
base gamma - that's a separate
sooo I don't know that looks silly if
you project it um now a value point
three I don't understand what that means
because for example for the elephant if
I were to go back to my elephant
wherever the elephant got to okay and I
were to say chromaticity plot of the
elephant comma point three what is it
gonna do the chances of you having any
point this one still okay okay so that's
kind of inconsistent right you've got to
make it up your mind and I think what
this should do is I mean I think that
second argument is kind of wrong because
that second argument is only applicable
to these sort of you know yeah whatever
well these things which have non you
know which have a higher dimension which
are higher dimensional objects these
points it's not you're not going to hit
a point ever so it's these higher
dimensional things like colors near
which is a 3d object or the gamut which
is also a 3d object correct um so what
is in that second argument in general
reference space or reference space and
the luminance value you were trying the
RGB as the reference but that could be
the default is XY Y okay so reference
space makes sense because it's a 3d
thing I mean this thing of point three
the problem is it's a it's a you know
you're defining the coordinate that is
not being plotted explicitly in the
chromaticity plot you're giving its
value here right yep I mean presumably
you really should give an interval of
some kind or something or you know
greater than that I think this is a mess
that second argument there Roger your
comments well-liked tend to agree with
you and I think that the slice is
valuable too but I think we need to look
at that more systematically now and
design the sign of subsystem shoddy and
I like the inner vault suggestion that
yeah I do too I think that there are
many things you know we
these things the slice plots did we
built now to where we look at things
also in this case they're also there I
mean the function form greater than of
0.3 and things like that is another I
don't know that's the right way to do it
but I think that what we concluded here
is that we want to sort of expand out
that subsystem and make it yes
you know consistence just I mean
systematic you know livestream is asking
about this what is this going to show
what the heck is this this is some kind
of eclipse
yeah this is like when you live in 2d
space and 3d impinges on flatland
yes um this is a growing neighborhood
around red there I that specified as the
r8 is the radius or the distance from
red and well this is just showing I mean
there's nothing particularly this is
showing that for some values here I
don't even know why it's piecewise
linear it isn't really piecewise of you
that's a resolution right okay but but
what this is showing is that as you
increase the distance in the red ball so
to speak you are eventually hitting
luminance value point zero one right so
this is a
a conic section in some sense in color
space if I'm not mistaken yeah that's
right that's actually a cone it's a
spherical section of a certain somehow
in color space okay so I don't think
that's as confusing as as some okay all
right let's just look at some comments
from a live stream and then we'll move
on to the next topic ah manually
annotate um can you manually do
annotations with like this absolutely if
you can feed in this Association to
highlight image you can feed in your own
Association as well um by drawing a
bounding box and having the bounding box
so say with some label yes I assume this
way exactly but I series there isn't
label support right now it's coming for
the bounding box no for it for imitates
highlight image right okay fair enough
um but I would I was also implicit you
know that's one thing to show the
picture of it the other interesting
operation which we'll get to now is to
create them you know you in order to for
instance for training you say that this
bounding box here you have to pounding
box and you give a tag or a label and
ylabel in the sense of training label
not label acid in the aisle is turned
right that somehow relates to our
annotation stuff which we are supposed
to be talking about in a minute here I
would assume that we can that you can
use annotations as the raw material for
training yeah I think so and which by
the way is not something classify for
example deal with right now okay let's
keep going here okay another comment
from Ali Hashmi for example in
fluorescence microscopy yes right
agreed okay next comment call-outs
should work in highlight image yes this
part of label stuff okay oh here's
another one a round should work in color
space plot or chromaticity plot that's
what is color space plot there isn't I
think you meant a good point yeah a
round should work in chromaticity plot
we know we're not there yet
um okay can you do image segmentation as
well as simple bounding boxes I think
the answer is yes you can make masks and
so on um somebody commenting that
different people have particularly the
females of the species have different
numbers of color cones um it's an
x-linked trait and yes yes the mantis
shrimp we do not support the mantis
shrimp market at this time it has some
ridiculous number of color sensors um we
do have some things that emulate dog
vision don't we yeah the plan was to
move on with some other animal vision it
just never got to the top of our
priority list how do we how do we do
bees or the mantis shrimp or whatever
which have things in the ultraviolet I'm
totally confused yeah I think it's
hopeless
um I mean but there are the pink
satellites also have vision in utter of
course I mean we nicely support multi
multi channel I mean hyperspectral
imaging has still not really caught on
um I think it might finally catch on
when people start instead of just
putting the masses you know by the time
the CCD camera resolution is
unbelievably high you might as well put
masks other than just RGB in front of
the pixels um somebody
showing me a I mean that some of the
applications of things like food
freshness and so on that are easy to
find spectrally right oh yeah I just
don't think we've yet um the okay
somebody with a cute RGB you should look
at this from the livestream that points
it to the community um okay question
when should users expect functions like
contrast enhancement I do not know of
these terms which I think I think it's
that good time actually with image it
just updates we should I should look at
those as well I saw the comment I'll
make it I'll make a note okay so those
are basically things that are part of
image adjust or they're different yeah
they are basically different kinds of
contrast enhancements stretch yeah
basically make light light or a dark
darker and so forth so why does image
adjust not essentially have I mean for
other things we have transfer functions
like for image 3d rendering we have
transfer functions do we not have a
transfer function I thought we did not
useful event like nonlinear gamma or
arbitrary gamma Corrections with curves
that we can't control and things like
that all we have all seen GUI elements
for that right you're right it is this
time to look at all of those so but I
thought we had a function that just took
different channels and map is the grant
transform okay that does um this maps
histogram of
to the theater to the other one and the
histogram transform interpolation I
think is the one that gives the
interpolation function right but what
what you're saying is okay so the
question is can we parameterize these
adjustments um okay anyway separate
separate thing
okay um okay comment here there's no
easy way to make masks on images for
training data
I think there's what we were talking
about that don't want to be able to do
that and then the only question is how
that feeds into the way that classify
works um but I think that that's a good
use case they're out of good use cases
for these annotations if you like but
that you know for machine learning
tagging and training it's good good use
case right you know I should add to our
list forum um my I keep this list of
potential projects for the summer school
and student projects and so on we should
add some about multispectral imaging
because I think there's some interesting
things to try to do like for example
standardization of the you know
false-color for infrared and so on which
we've never we've never done um if you
can just send back mail about that I
know I'll add it to my list okay um okay
and I'm not gonna discuss the how do you
visualize different photoreceptors and
mantis shrimp I have thought about that
in the past um you know it's well it's
an interesting never mind I said I would
not discuss it it's an interesting case
of you know how humans represent things
or think about things that humans cannot
directly perceive um okay
all right let's keep going here in the
spectrogram okay that's
let's see this questions about using
deformable splines making masks people
using Fiji for image processing I don't
know what that means she's another
software I think he's suggesting some
kind of interactive tool to specify
splines around say the region of
interest and then use that as a mask or
initial marker for sizing which is a
question of our drawing tools which we
certainly have but they're just kind of
coming and in fact you should um this
but it doesn't require draw and this
would be image attached cell for image
you know to just put enough no I
understand that I understand that you
know this if Noah is working on those
things you might add that to the list
okay um okay let's see
questions about stereo images and masks
for objects and stereo images which I
don't think we're dealing with right
very well right now
is that true I mean we don't have a a
good we don't have a wrapper we could
one day have a wrapper called stereo
image symbolic wrapper would that not
make any sense I mean we have images
with depth maps right we can we can do
that but I don't know how we represent
those we talked about having it special
constructs for that I think we should do
yeah and possibly a special construct
for stereo image which would have
partial information of that kind right
all right we're gonna
gears hittin the spectrogram ah so so
are you okay so in the spectrogram so if
I say something like if I say well I do
an audio capture hello LOL oh okay so
now I say spectrogram of that wait a
minute isn't in a spectrum and the
spectrogram array I have to try this
let's see if I do speech recognizer I
wonder if it's going to work so speech
recognizer a percent 37 right okay but
now what is inverse spectrogram do
that's operating on oh let's fast yeah I
set it to fast
I'm just surprised that the language
model could generate that anyway um so
you really wanted a spectrogram audio
function that takes the spectrogram
which is not gonna work with that color
function we're using in spectrogram by
the way you should probably do
spectrogram of that color function
grayscale you you really wanted a
spectrogram audio that takes that
spectrogram the power spectrogram and
generates the audio back especially our
array that one gives the data on their
spectrogram know in the spectrogram
array would make more sense right
oh I mean inverse spectrogram from an
image seems completely crazy doesn't it
how do I get the spectrogram okay the
spectrogram is kind of end of the line
it's just a picture right but sexual
gram array spectrogram array by the way
this thing with the cursor not becoming
a vertical eye beam is driving me nuts
um did you already report that my new
okay but all right
okay so spectrogram array is gonna make
some giant array okay why isn't this a
numeric array object by the way
we can't make it we didn't have numeric
arrays when when we introduced this
function but also I think we are staying
a little conservative not introducing
the America raise from arrays are not
mature yet Stephen what you can actually
do with them okay fine all right but so
one day this might be a numeric array
yeah then the idea here is that in the
spectrogram operates on this thing is
that correct correct okay so if I say in
the spectrogram of that I'll get a
stupid error jokes okay well what it was
it supposed to be fed real values you
you in very spectrogram really expect
the power spectrograph not the complex
values I guess I can make a case for
this to work as well it should work yeah
okay so how do I get the power spectrum
out of this power spectrogram out of
this
Ronen apps or square okay this is really
weird if I might say so so okay so let's
take ABS
did have examples that you wanted to
convert the image to audio or to an ass
that's what you want your highest and
you wish to see them okay let's try this
anyway and then you still get your
numbers back yeah the idea is that this
is a audio of that correct
you know one other thing is is I can't
hear I wonder how I set it to be able to
hear it
his it sounds like I can imitate it
because yeah I'm well the thing is that
if you when you create the spectrogram
you transpose and get the half so you
actually have to implement that from so
really the assumption for this inverse
spectrogram function was that we are
giving the image of the spectrogram so
already the transpose have you know
chopped right so hold on so you're
telling me if I take that spectrogram
there and I say inverse spectrogram of
that image yeah Carla and I have talked
about this maybe this doesn't work yeah
well open the ref page for that maybe
that would help
again since you hadn't seen this ever I
didn't put it in the builds you should
open it in CVS we can make rosters work
fix rosters but and get the data out the
problem is with these default or any
arbitrary color functions okay this
there's many layers of weirdness going
on here okay I mean the basic thing that
we want to be able to do is to take a
spectrogram you know let's say you
artistically create a spectrogram and
then you want to basically generate
audio from the spectrogram application
example sorry I should have moved that
off well that's a baboon okay and you're
telling me that that I can now listen to
the ribbon sure should be mostly noise
it's mostly noise is the variant I mean
I was expecting it to sound like a
baboon Oh eventually we'll image
identify that the um okay what is this
now that's what I'm hearing music from
that but okay okay what should this
function actually do this function
should be taking so at the core but
there's some administration around it
which i think is a little funky but at
the core what it does it takes the real
spectrogram and it tries to reconstruct
the face so it's it has to fill in with
models what it the data doesn't provide
yes but okay so but
two different things I mean one is
taking the true spectrogram and just
reconstructing audio from it the true
complex spectrogram right that one now
are on their short time for your family
that we already said a lot we have short
time for a year which also keeps what
was the original object whether it was a
list and all your a time series okay and
then we have in very short time for you
so if you do have the phase data that's
the proper way of look there's going to
be something in the family spectrogram
array which is giving you phase data I
mean I don't understand why spectrogram
array gives you face station and
spectrogram does not in sensor and sorry
I said that wrong given that spectrogram
is losing phase data should spectrogram
array also lose phase data or have some
way to specify the lose phase data
hmm makes sense because especially now
that is a redundant functionality with
short time for you short time for you
creates a short time for your data
I don't know this field well enough to
know when you say spectrogram do you
expect complex phases or not I would
have thought so ya know the spectrogram
is just a plot well there may be look
maybe spectrogram array should just be
the you know you know maybe it should be
the case that's late for that I mean
things are different now because at the
time as Charlie said we were trying to
do we know that the plot losing half the
data yes okay
and so spectrogram array was trying to
fill that gap
but the true the real thing is
short-term Fourier transform that's what
one should be using for a sort of full
fidelity yes and it has many
applications yep yep yep yes rather than
spate really I mean spectrogram is just
a show me a basic picture but then the
problem is the inverse of that that is
given a picture what does the sound is
is surely worthwhile and both cases of
the give me you know draw me a picture
because most artists don't draw in
complex values so to speak you know draw
me a picture and then infer the face
data and play it and potentially well I
think that's the most common case so is
it the case that spectrogram array if I
were to do okay so what happens if I say
now um ABB's
a percent forty and then I just say
array plot of that do I get the
spectrogram no I get this bizarre thing
would be but the two different branches
of the spectrogram it is the duplicated
I know I know I know I know so why isn't
it the case I would have expected that
spectrogram array would basically give
me the numbers in the spectrogram now I
admit that the the plot in other words
the thing we want to be able to do is to
let people essentially make one of these
plots themselves right so that's what
were the most natural way of specifying
the numbers that appear in their in
their spectral graph yeah I mean it's
obviously it's weird I mean if it's an
image for example let's see which way to
as an image coordinate system go Irish
coordinate system goes up it doesn't it
that's similar to what you see in that
spectrogram 0 0 as is that bottomless
right so 0 times there a frequency
bottom left yep
so if it was an image you know one could
imagine it's a little weird well okay so
one could imagine some kind of
spectrogram image I'm not happy with
this right and inverse spectrogram image
it's not quite right but that's the type
of thing I mean like your baboon for
example is that's presumably your your
gray scaling the baboon and then using
it to render the UM intensity in those
positions is that correct
exactly so for example if I were to take
that friendly creature why do you need
to okay you're doing an image rotate
that's now built in again not updated my
bad just passed a image to image but but
but but if I rather want to take this
thing okay so let's take this guy and
that's edge detect him because then I
think it won't be noise well night still
be noise it's got a very super fluffy
creature um how do i how do I get
something I've edge detect a point of
like four or something here okay
whatever
okay there we go there's the baboon
sketch the Picasso but baboon okay so
now I feed that to him a spectrogram
right I say audio of them a spectrogram
of this is that correct quick
you
you
you
oh this is really cool you can put it up
on sue like how do I do that
expand your audio object with the arrows
make the big interface now click the
speaker
we'll have to change the device yeah no
no Steven no go back out don't even buy
out this one yeah now click the speaker
they're zoom audio device yes okay this
could be bad everybody can anybody here
no you have to also share your zoom on
the very top it says add share or
something
well um new share sorry we don't see
your soul
correct
well sounded like a bird to me yeah it's
the baboon's friend um okay okay so I
feel like saving this file because kind
of bizarre with interesting things in it
um okay hold on a second here okay all
right so so look with respect to the
spectrogram thing um shoot we're not I
mean this is really a shame because
you're saying with a pure image here we
can get the audio out of the image but
how do we get an image from the ordinary
spectrogram how do we get an image from
this spectrogram
so I mean it's little ornery right I
mean because you have to then get rid of
the decorations in the decorations
arguably spectrogram should have some
argument where it just gives an image
grayscale as well because color function
is in the way - yeah I understand
oh I didn't know he had leaves that's a
sensible idea um well I'm not certain
what we should do here I mean so it's
it's not a streamlined as it can be
because but if you get rid of there the
frames and stuff and you just get them
really hacky I mean that's really really
hacky no I agree
is this an image in fact or is this
smell oh it's graphic graphics yeah so
that's a real hacker Lola that's a plot
its plot
is it it looks bitmap II it's a raster
it's a graphics of a raster yeah okay
okay I see inspector graphics of a
raster um and we experimented a little
bit taking the raster out it's always
RGB even if it it's it even if you use a
grayscale color function and so forth
we decided to just leave it out for now
and just go with images or data well I
don't understand the data case I don't
understand the format of the data is the
data a list of intensity value I mean of
you know is it what it should be is
going up from zero at each at each row I
mean each each at each time value it
should be the intensity for frequency
zero blah blah blah up up that way right
that makes sense yes in fact then what
it is is it's the if this was an image
those values will be arranged in the
same way that they would be in the image
left to right bottom to top so you want
the inverse spectrogram of image to be
equivalent to inverse spectrogram of
image data of the image that's what I'm
suggesting yes yeah I discussed that to
Carlo I I agree that that's more a lot
more intuitive great Pat again okay so
then the question is how can you get an
image on a spectrogram we've never
really had
that issue of getting an image from
because we've never tried to process
things from an image but I think I think
this design for him a spectrogram we
just described is reasonable and if it
is it will normally not take complex
values but if it is given complex values
it will use the complex values okay yep
that makes sense
okay so then then the only thing that
remains here is to see how spectrogram
can generate an image I mean there's a
hacky way to do it with method Aero
image or something but that's really
hacky Roger do you have any thoughts
about this and I think it violates our
design rule to changing type yeah I
think it sort of has to be an argument
just about if you want it yeah you know
it's like format almost like we have for
many other functions like what is the
output that you want but it's all filled
up with a bunch of other things the
arguments there yes which are necessary
except during the problem is as we've
discussed before inverse spectrogram
requires knowing you know frequency what
the actual values correspond to right
how have you done that here I see so
you're basically mirroring the arguments
here that's correct
do you think some value range
specification is gonna be useful there I
think I think so yeah I think so but but
okay what is the role of spectrogram
array what is spectrogram array
why isn't spectrogram array spectrogram
away used to be what short-term Fourier
transforms all right so spectrogram
array should be the image data that can
be fed to inverse spectrogram well the
image data like array that could be fed
to in a spectrogram I don't think we
want to change the dimensions of
spectrogram array so that it's
transposed like what the data on their
spectrogram is people are very much used
to seeing frequency sounds to me like
spectrogram array is gonna be a dead
function soon I think so as well that's
my guess but I it's also released
version 9 I would be a little worried
about change I mean we just couldn't
leave it well so the possibility is
spectrogram image is a possible thing if
we think that's useful
I think it's sufficiently useful we can
make a spectrogram image produce a
grayscale image may be a plot theme can
control that as well an obscure say
really obscure that that's I mean this
is definitely in the well I mean it all
relies on sort of how how common and
useful is that case I know I know
because because what I'm imagining is
here's what I'm imagining that people
take the spectrogram image they do image
processing operations on it then they do
inverse spectrogram on it to play it
correct
that's the case in that case I think we
should actually have spectrogram image
okay it'll track the standard feed stat
workflow
here's a way to generate an image
process and go to town
fine let's do it okay okay and that's
okay we have run out of time here
except let me just take a very very very
quick look at Web Audio search is it in
there is it in this some way to act
remote for it
rough page in CVS or just play with it
should work well okay so let's try one
thing here okay so if I say Web Audio
search for I should probably regret this
but anyway baboon okay something going
on with the service connect I don't know
what does that mean that's really weird
I mean does that mean that my how can
that possibly be working I'm you know no
there's nothing wrong with my connection
I don't know
moving free sound to the cloud so that
we can we were just basically patching
this correctly for authentication and
things like that
oh you're guessing in the past few days
it must have changed all right okay well
listen we have not finished here
unfortunately we're going to need yet
another meeting
um I think really this is annotations we
have discussed if you briefly look at
what Roger has in the notebook four
symbols are going live in 12 that's the
first annotation delete annotation rules
audio annotate and audio annotation book
it's gonna be very audio specific in 12
and 12 one is gonna do the real release
of annotations where properties are
renamed and more objects are going to
support annotations so you know I'm just
saying that what do they correspond to
in the property framework when there was
something corresponding to it okay I
guess the errors are gone the other way
yeah okay okay audiotape yes look up did
we discuss that
what are your annotation look up not
really but this is a very rich lookup
function that allows for looking for any
tags at any time or time interval for
any value it's it's a very useful lookup
function this is all executed in general
kind of expect I wouldn't surprise me
Stephen as we do more annotation across
more objects that will have lookup
functions that are particularly useful
for that class of object I understand
that it wouldn't surprise me but it's
what it seems to me it's going towards
right but we have too little of our
experience basis a little slightly small
yet I understand that okay two questions
from our live stream and then we need to
wrap here um from afar Oh burn inspector
asking a spectrogram of n'ver
spectrogram VAX the identity um and the
answer is not precisely because
spectrogram spectrogram image of in
spectrogram of an image would give the
same
back again correct no not necessary that
correct yes it is correct but it depends
on the way that it does a complex value
interpolation right it depends on how it
reconstructs to face yes but in other
words so the phase deconstruction so to
speak or the phase removal the question
is is the phase removal the inverse of
the phase when you get rid of the phase
again do you get back okay you've got an
amp our value I see what you're saying
it's right does that work correctly so
power value you reconstruct the phase
you spectrogram fi which means you're
only getting the power value again do
you get back to the same thing you had
before it seems like we should but we
should check right okay um
question will Web Audio search cost
money like web image search
what's the unfortunately now and
unfortunately yes in the first release
because it will do added stuff
our goal is another subsystem which will
allow it to be not cost money but you
will supply credentials for the services
that you want to use you only need to do
it once you store it in a in in some of
the front end settings and you can
manage the services that you want to
activate or not activate well using
system credentials and using all of that
whole apparatus that we have for storing
I mean service connect right now you
give your credentials when you do the
service connection but with the fact
that we can now hook into system
keychains you don't have to do that so
that's that's an important aspect there
would you point out Siemens because we
if you're going to store your credit so
the point is that if your store
credentials for the different services
that we hook up to Web Audio search then
it's free but then it needs to be stored
securely yes it is this a big as an
internal there's a bunch of internal
projects going on to make sure that we
can responsibly store credential where
there's one project which is the system
keychain project I mean you don't need
to do your own system keychain but no no
I know we don't we're waiting for it
that is it not finished I mean I thought
I could say system credential we were
trying to use it and I ever didn't work
properly shoddy actually I'm not sure
really proper prop
he tried because I wasn't sure it's
that's there an operational working well
that's bad but that's the plan that's
the plan to do that and use it do you
want to quickly see the results of Web
Audio search I feel like we're really
done with the wrap-up review in order to
avoid it separate meeting for just a one
function I think we've got a few items
here that were trailing anyway well I
think this is we decided okay hold on
wait a minute
image feature track function has a lot
of potential with tracking okay that's
good
you can add some option to get rid of
occlusions for a certain number of
frames example okay this is details for
you about image image feature track okay
you want to show me something on the
screen
yep as you suggested earlier web all
your search now has the second argument
that default is data set so for the
baboon I get the data set of three the
function has max item said Max's to ten
by default but I'm still absorbing this
baboon here um okay so you did a web
audio search what is player here so the
best one and lies you to play the single
audio okay and then to pick from the
ones that Peter is gonna be the gallery
view that you can actually say I like
this one after maybe you play what are
those pictures of those are those some
spectrograms
those yeah these are spectrogram default
colors these come from the service yep
they come from the service even there
there are some nails provided by this
service okay not produced by us but one
thing that's super important for both of
these they don't pull in the audio they
have links to it and you stream it
through that player
a little wet okay no no you can get it
you know that's if you want to pull in
that first that first thing there show
me how to pull in Ming's baboon sorry
which one so I was just going to go to
freesound
to show you okay so it's a baboon from
the Wellington Zoo oh wait you don't
show me the two cases there this is the
spectrogram they also have their
waveform
okay why don't we have a green and red
spectrogram why do we only have a one
color one Heuer do they have more
information in there is that just note
they don't have motivation just a color
yeah okay do we have that color function
as well red red blue green kind of a
color function I don't know okay so
let's go back here to show me the
workflow to get that um means for boom
yes a copy and paste copy paste
there it is okay so now if you say
spectrogram of that why do you have to
say sub one that was announced Oh
no but yeah you've got to evaluate that
okay no but I'm asking why the spectra
cannot take a list and return a list of
spectrograms that's a I guess
never-ending question how many are how
many of the functions should work on a
list and return the list we can make
that work well or unless the spectrogram
of a list should mean something
different I think I think we should not
jump to doing that cuz I'm not sure what
it should mean okay that's a
weird-sounding that's oh wow Wow well
you can play it shadi for us you know so
we can hear it
yeah shadi she's playing it I heard it
um okay my invitation wasn't very good
okay um all right
is this really everything that we need i
I think we managed to you with the
microphone not truth is I think we think
this is it Stephen if I if I'm correct
going through my notes from today okay
wait for 12 okay sounds good all right
both thank you all thank you for lots of
useful comments on the live stream and
encouragement and talk to you all soon